só hoje vou mostrar aquela mania que o
destino último vídeo da armadilha
amorim foi só uma mas pronto o que uma
armadilha que eu gostaria
a crise está por fazer vários tipos de
armadilhas
usando o mesmo mecanismo então gostei
logo em seguida isso aqui está tudo aqui
está a mostrar que a partir do mesmo
organismo chegar o outro tipo permitir
mecanismos muito versátil e está
armadilha ao contrário da outra que
deixava o machucado
isso aqui vai deixar o animal
estrangulado e vai deixar no chão é
pronto
ao contrário das outras armadilhas que
encontrará pista de laço que deixam um
ícone mal pendurado suspenso enquanto o
selinho usar água leite com um ramo que
inverteu dobrar em fazer passar essa
parte da extremidade e inteiro a volta
de 15 centímetros na terra que é muito
fácil eu sei que eu passei mesmo aqui
fazer um golaço o laço é bastante
simples fazer essa fazer uma espécie de
lagoa e depois passar a linha uma idéia
a bola só podem usar esticar
sobrevivência podem enfrentar lá em casa
mas podem desmontar a noite já ninguém o
ônibus ficará seja melhor pensar do
produto para montar uma armadilha que
está ali na linha tronco passa por cima
do gol está bom então
eu nunca prometi temos nesse dia o
mantenha os dragados bang bang porque eu
gosto de chiang e não tem nada a ver com
isso comprou os casais têm nenhum cheiro
mesmo intensa e um sabor também não fala
quanto mais pequeno mais saboroso é não
se iludam pelo tamanho que vocês vêem
estão mercados que não tem nada a ver em
quanto mais quente mais tenebroso são
vocês podem plantar em casa e ver a
diferença entre a nintendo irá se
quiserem claro é que o promotor
armadilha já montada
você tem tapado lado extremamente
limitada único animal só pode entrar na
zona onde está escrito isso podem ter
para 50 anos e coisa é mais pontos é só
colocar sua vivência funcionar a
armadilha
então deixa o animal no chão no fica
suspensa
só espero que tenham gostado muito bom
gosto e não gosto comenta nossas coisas
e ao próximo